the jurogan experience was it
disappointing
like being on congress in congress and
and
seeing that kind of behavior like if you
have this ideal
of what a representative of our
democracy is supposed to be
and then seeing people that are petty
and that are
sneaky and doing little wasn't this was
my first
impression getting elected uh got
elected 2012
got there and sworn in in january of
2013
and uh i remember um calling home i
think i was talking to my my family my
parents or somebody and i was like
this place is like high school even on
the house floor that that's the only
time we're all together usually for
votes
when you've got everybody all 435
members there and you see the little
clicks
gathering in their designated corners
like the cafeteria tables and
uh you know one click is kind of you
know giving the mean girls side eye to
the other clique and like oh if you're
you're hanging out on that side of the
room with those people what's wrong with
you
really yeah man it's it's i mean it's
it's funny but it's so terrible when you
understand that
this is the power base for decision
making in our country
and you like how is this even possible
it's possible because
so often people will vote for
a candidate because like they have a
really cool ad on tv
or like yeah that that person you know
is a good looking guy or a good looking
girl or
they talk good they talk nice sounds
smart yeah all right
check rather than like all right
what are your capabilities what are your
qualifications
like what kind of judgment will you
exercise
in making decisions that affect
literally every single
aspect of our lives as americans in this
country
and so it's terrible that we have
um this kind of makeup in our in our
government but also like we as voters
have to do a much
the power's in our hands ultimately in
how we're making decisions
uh in choosing who gets to work for us
and not forgetting that not forgetting
that those people who work in the united
states capital they work
for us when it comes right down to it
and so we have the power to hire and
fire
i think that people have developed such
a sophisticated
way of manipulating folks that
the thing about running for office
particularly running for president it's
it's one of the weirdest things where
the most important job ever yeah you
don't have to be qualified
you just have to be chosen so you don't
have to have
any experience in government you don't
even really have to know
how government works all you have to do
is get enough
people that are willing to give you a
try and you can have the nuclear
football
like not saying trump i'm not saying
biting but
if someone comes along some ridiculously
popular person
that knows absolutely nothing about
government but they're like
justin bieber he wants to be president i
[ __ ] love that guy
like that is not outside of the realm of
possibility
all you if if you have some incredibly
charismatic person
and you you like them over marco rubio
or whoever the [ __ ] it is ted cruz
you're like well that guy sucks
this guy can sing his ass off let's go
with him like but
you're literally giving someone the
power to run the greatest army the world
has ever known
the the the most insanely
advanced civilization on earth and the
one with the most weapons
you're gonna let a person who wins a
popularity contest
they can run this yeah man i mean i i
lived through this
i literally just lived through this but
what's the alternative
well people first of all need to kind of
have the veil
lifted yes on on on what this
is and how both political parties play
into this and the media plays into this
you know i saw from from the very
day that i announced my candidacy for
president you know i ran for president
on uh out of concern of some very real
issues
that our country is facing wanting to
bring voice to those issues and actually
do something about it
uh the the the rise of of north korea's
nuclear capabilities for example
and how we in hawaii lived through
the reality of that threat when we got
that that missile alert
that came through that caused you know
families to to go and like
tell people about that real quick so so
this was january 2019
uh early one saturday morning
the civil defense alert system on our
state sent out a text message to every
cell phone in the state
blared warnings on the radios the
the sirens on television saying
missile incoming to hawaii
uh this is not a drill take shelter
this is not a drill and
so the response to that was
like holy [ __ ] this could be
the end an incoming missile to hawaii
from north korea
would literally mean the destruction not
only of hawaii but
the the aftermath and everything else
would would imp have a much much bigger
impact so
that's how people responded you know
grabbing their little kids and running
in like where do you take shelter like
going into the bathtub and hunkering
down there was a
a father's a video of a father who got
his like little eight-year-old
daughter and lowered her down a manhole
and was was i i think he said something
in the video like if we survive this
try to come find me
and there there are countless other
stories of
of i heard from from a father
who he had one child who was in downtown
honolulu
the other was on the west side of oahu
which is a good 45 minute
drive and he was physically in the
middle and and
in those moments
he was sitting there knowing he had
minutes to live
trying to decide which child he was
going to go and
drive to and spend those last minutes of
life
with
the seriousness of this is something
that
has and continues to be lost
on the leaders of our country and this
was one of the main reasons that i ran
for president so that i could do
something to make sure that
no other american no other family went
through what
we went through in hawaii on that day
i announced my candidacy for president
so that we can talk about these very
serious issues
and on day one immediately literally
that very day within minutes
mainstream media starts attacking that's
when the whole russian
asset thing began these seeds were
planted to say oh she's some kind of
suspicious candidate you better watch
out
the smears started the building of this
caricature
of of me as something that has nothing
to do with who i am my experience my
background my capabilities
what i'm advocating for no the media
didn't want to talk about that
the the the other candidates didn't want
to talk about it
going on the debate stage okay i'm gonna
this is a national stage to be able to
raise these very serious issues about
the the the nuclear threat that our
country faces this new cold war and
what we need to do to walk back away
from the brink of nuclear catastrophe
nobody wants to talk about it they want
to go towards the the superficial
attacks they want to go towards the he
said versus she said and
ultimately the things that will cause
ratings to go up
and that will further this this
popularity contest
that you're talking about which
ultimately all of this
is the ultimate disservice to voters
because it takes away their ability to
make this informed decision
about who should hold the nuclear
football and what experience they bring
what kind of judgment
they would bring what kind of foresight
they bring to this most
powerful and important job and
responsibility
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between
video and audio experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience